if uh you mentioned this quote on one of
your uh live streams i think if you save
one life you save the world yeah
that's such a cool line i think i
remember reading about paul farmer i
think his name is he's a doctor that
really
i mean um doctors in general they kind
of don't care about
like what they're doing as a broad
policy across
hundreds of thousands of millions of
people they just care about the human in
front of them which is so interesting
they don't care it's gonna cost like in
his case to save one child it will cost
him hundreds of thousands of dollars
they don't care about that they can't
they know very well that what their
actions cannot be scaled
but they can't help but help the child
in front of them and it's so interesting
that's such an interesting way to live
and that's the way i kind of think when
i try to do something positive
is
will this help one person
and i just kind of imagine a specific
person depending on the thing
that that would help with like what i'm
trying to create something whether it's
a piece of hardware or or a video or
anything like that or
educational material lecture that kind
of stuff
i don't know what what do you think
about this quote like what
is it profound or just just poetic i
think it's more profound than it sounds
at first uh the example i think of is
michelle bachman she was a former
congresswoman from minnesota she clearly
had crazy eyes something weird is going
on with the husband but she adopted like
like 20 kids tara shepard's another
friend of mine he's like a either navy
seal or marines i whatever is terry i
polish i'm not trying to be funny and he
adopts like elder dogs so
going back to bachmann it's like yeah
you can say she's crazy you can make fun
of her politics all you want and all
that stuff's legitimate
but if you save a kid
give them a home and you save them from
the foster system
and you put a roof over their heads and
make them feel loved and appreciated
it's really hard for me
to sit here and call you
like a totally bad person
i think that kind of thing is nick
cersei's another one he adopted a kid
and i said you're i think you're a hero
like if you there's someone you know one
of the things that's very hard for me
i'm writing as you know i talk about
this endlessly this book the white pill
but writing about when people do hurtful
things to children
it really is hard to watch and it's hard
to because when you're an author you
have to kind of empathize with the
character you have to where's this
character coming from explain their
point of view and that's the one that's
the hardest for me to wrap my head
around like cruelty to children yeah or
or
and yeah sadism to children it's just
like this is a
this is something even animals know not
to do you know what i mean like dogs are
right when you see them around kids
they're very
protective like if the kid pokes their
eyes out the dog doesn't do anything
so it's like if you can't even get to
that level
uh what kind of person are you so i
think that quote um
is a profound one and it's an important
one uh it also means
we're not all called upon to be superman
right you only have very finite ability
to move the needle
but at the same time
if you have actually you know saved the
life
you can go to meet your maker you you
did your part you know you left the
world a little bit better than you found
it and that's all you could ask anybody
also i think from a policy perspective
it seems we just do better when we focus
on doing a small thing helping uh
helping one person because it feels like
when you start talking about communism
and all those kinds of things when you
start to believe you could do good by a
lot of people that's where your mind
somehow
stops being able to do good by a lot of
people that's when you start to think
about utopias and somehow utopia's ghost
feeds power into the brain to where it
deludes you completely and then you
start
it's okay to crack a few eggs to make an
omelet kind of reasoning and you run
into trouble it seems like it's much
better
even when you have the power and the
money and so on to achieve scale to
focus on one
and then
or locally yeah locally yeah right
because then suppose you have the
feedback exactly right so if you have
some kind of program you know in austin
or brooklyn or something like that and
you're you can you can watch oh this is
working this isn't working then you
could port it out to other places but
top down helping is you know
at the very least it's going to be
inefficient and also i think it's a lot
more useful when you're helping people
when it's a one-on-one
relationship because then it's less
embarrassing but certainly less
something to receive help and you also
feel if it's one thing if you get a
check from the government you know food
stamps it's nothing if someone's like
hey i'm gonna buy you groceries until
you get back on your feet you have this
kind of motivation i think for most
people to be like you know what this
person believed in me i'm going to
make it worth their while that they
believed in me yes i didn't believe in
me
yeah i had when i was giving lectures at
mit there was one um was scarce shitless
and uh and everybody you know how
students are and all that kind of stuff
they're kind of bored yeah and they
don't they don't understand that you're
human too they're yeah
[Laughter]
or this is it could be just me but they
don't understand you're trying to pass
this human i know uh but there's one one
uh gentleman in the audience and he went
to all the lectures uh all the gentlemen
he was a faculty at mit and he just
without very kind of nonchalant just
said uh after the lectures you kind of
nod at me and say you did great
and uh before like one time he said in a
non-creepy way i know this is gonna come
off as creepy he said uh
you look great today
like he said that you know um i don't in
the way so he's like 60 70 whatever like
he
in this i don't know it's in a wise sage
way because i was wearing a suit and tie
like i look like you know when you dress
up like a young kid yeah yeah
so he was just like all right
yeah you're uh you're all dressed up
you're like great yeah you got this i
don't know that has a lasting impact
that kind of pat on the back but i agree
with you um
cruelty towards other
adults
is somehow understandable
because it's a
world full of conflict but cruelty
towards children
doesn't
it doesn't quite
i can't i can't understand it
i can't understand how you could
act in a way that directly causes
suffering to a child in front of you
you